[Musica]
ho una grandissima passione che è quella
per i viaggi viaggi all'avventura in
particolare viaggi che mi hanno permesso
di scoprire molte parti del mondo e di
entrare in contatto con molte culture e
civiltà locali e poi sono madre sono
padre di due splendidi bambini anzi
quasi ragazze perché se mi sentono
definirle bambini si arrabbiano lo
scorso anno lavorativo avete sentito i
numeri dell'azienda è stato un anno
estremamente impegnativo che mi ha visto
molto molto spesso lontano da casa non
solo fisicamente ma anche mentalmente e
quest'estate con i miei figli abbiamo
deciso di farci un regalo tutto nostro e
di organizzare un viaggio solo per noi
un viaggio come piace a noi
all'avventura abbiamo noleggiato un
minivan un westfalia e siamo partiti
alla scoperta di creta per immergerci in
noi stessi e nella natura è stato
un'avventura meravigliosa fino al giorno
in cui per fortuna guarda alla fine del
viaggio il mio telefono il mio
smartphone ha deciso di abbandonarci e
voi non potete capire non so se a voi è
mai successa una cosa del genere
il panico che gli ho provato in quel
momento ovviamente ero sola con due
bambini loro non hanno un telefono nel
mio telefono io tengo qualsiasi cosa
dalle carte d'imbarco
l'itinerario che volevo fare anche se
era un viaggio avventura un minimo
dentro il telefono le tappe che avrei
voluto fare ce le avevo gli orari delle
aerei o tutto lì io non so un numero di
telefono a mente non so voi ma io so il
mio e su quella del the bubble i miei
bambini e quindi non sapeva nemmeno chi
chiamare ma soprattutto ero dalla parte
opposta di creata rispetto a dover all
aeroporto e non avevo neanche un app da
utilizzare offline delle mappe il nostro
magico google map che ci accompagna
ovunque io non sono più capaci neanche
di trovare casa mia tra un po se non
inserisco l'indirizzo su google map
poi fortunatamente sono riuscita a
tornare a casa e allora ho riflettuto ho
riflettuto e ho pensato ma veramente noi
oggi siamo diventati così schiavi della
tecnologia
io ricordo iniziato a viaggiare avevo
diciotto diciannove anni
non ce li avevamo i telefoni non avevamo
lo smartphone e non avevamo tutti questi
strumenti
mi sono trovata in situazioni
particolarmente di disagio come quando
ho finito la benzina in the middle of
nowhere in bolivia ho forato al confine
tra la namibia e l'angola non avevamo
telefoni ma ce la siamo cavata e senza
neanche troppo panico
allora mi sono veramente domandata e ho
riflettuto ma perché noi oggi siamo così
schiavi di tutte queste tecnologie e
questa sua fazione talmente subdola che
spesso non ci rendiamo conto di essere
così vittime così schiavi ma perché le
tecnologie oggi sono talmente
intelligenti che sono semplici da
utilizzare
pensate quando dovete andare a prenotare
un albergo un ristorante guardare se
tagliarlo
che cosa utilizzate avrete lo smartphone
è andata a guardare le recensioni
non voglio fare i nomi di app insomma le
conoscete tutte se dovesse trovare un
indirizzo ripeto e non ce l'avete più la
cartina in macchina aprite il telefono
per qualsiasi cosa ormai lo shopping
online
andare a confrontare i vari prezzi
scegliere il prodotto
siamo veramente vittime dei nostri
apparati tecnologici e quindi qua io
vorrei in questi dieci minuti ormai che
sono rimasti 15 minuti fare una
riflessione insomma voi una
chiacchierata su come il nostro ego e le
tecnologie intelligenti possono
coesistere
oppure noi possiamo utilizzarle al
nostro vantaggio per andare a facilitare
alcuni lavori alcune attività che sono
ripetitive che sono noiose e quindi per
aumentare il livello del nostro stile di
vita e cogliere più opportunità e per
farlo a questa riflessione vorrei
partire da una frase di bernardo di
chartres e scusate la pronuncia so che
non è corretta
una frase che è stata detta all'incirca
nel 1100 durante un dibattito tra
la conoscenza antica e la conoscenza
contemporanea è ancora valida nonostante
siano passati tutti questi anni
noi siamo come nani sulle spalle di
giganti così che possiamo vedere più
cose di loro è più lontane non certo per
l'acume della vista all altezza del
nostro corpo ma perché siamo sollevati
ha portato in alto dalla statura dei
giganti questa eccezione negativa
ciò significa che noi oggi veramente se
lo riportiamo ai giorni nostri siamo
vittime della tecnologia non ci
impegniamo più a guardare oltre
prendiamo quello che ci dà la tecnologia
ci adattiamo e non andiamo a sfruttare
le potenzialità nelle varie
conversazioni che ho fatto oggi durante
il pranzo ma è stato anche ripreso dei
relatori precedenti sento dire che i
giovani oggi penso che sia per tutto
perché hanno facile accesso alle
informazioni
pensano di saper tutto pensano di saper
tutto perché è facile accedere alle
informazioni ma in maniera superficiale
e difficilmente anno lo stimolo di
andare in profondità ecco io questo
messaggio lo voglio girare in maniera
positiva perché tendenzialmente sono una
persona che vede il bicchiere mezzo
pieno
noi abbiamo la responsabilità tutti di
farci delle domande di utilizzare le
tecnologie per vincere le sfide e
migliorare il nostro stile di vita e
cogliere maggiori opportunità isaac
newton rispondeva alla frase precedente
dicendo che se ho visto più lontano è
perché sono salito sulle spalle dei
giganti io ho deciso di salire sulle
spalle dei giganti perché so che è un
opportunità e questo è un concetto che
va trasferito alle nuove generazioni
avendo due fili vengo spesso buttata
dentro i dibattiti tra mamme tra
genitori quando dobbiamo dare lo
smartphone figli è giusto darglielo
ma i bambini piccoli è giusto ci
utilizzo in un ipad
sapete oggi appena un bambino nasce sa
già che col ditino deve andare a giocare
su ipad sullo smartphone è giusto
io personalmente scusate non è che una
legge io personalmente ritengo che sia
assolutamente giusto ma deve essere
fatto nella maniera corretta andando ad
educare le nuove generazioni
su cosa si può fare con le tecnologie su
come debbano essere utilizzati ma non
come si scrive un codice che a scuola lo
insegnano già dalle elementari ma
l'utilizzo etico delle tecnologie con le
tecnologie oggi noi possiamo far
tantissimo
si sente parlare della risparmio
energetico ultimamente del plastic free
google elon musk utilizzano intelligenza
artificiale per la riduzione dei consumi
energetici per l'ottimizzazione e questo
è qualcosa che alle nuove generazioni
dobbiamo trasferire l'utilizzo etico
delle tecnologie questo non solo perché
se lo ritroveranno nel mondo del lavoro
ma anche per evitare quei casi di cyber
bullismo di cui troppo spesso sentiamo
parlare in televisione
quindi spero vivamente che non è un
ruolo solo di noi fa delle famiglie di
noi addetti ai lavori ma anche e
soprattutto della scuola e della società
quindi spero assolutamente che
all'interno del dei corsi a scuola delle
elezioni venga introdotto sentito dire
che vi introdurranno educazione civica
ma anche un'educazione digitale quindi
all'utilizzo degli apparati digitali
dicevo una generazione che devono
imparare ma noi stessi dobbiamo imparare
a convivere con le tecnologie digitali
perché ormai è pervasivo in qualsiasi
tipo di lavoro non solo nelle nostre
vite quotidiane ma anche e soprattutto
all'interno dei nostri lavori e anche in
maniera estremamente positiva basti
pensare ad esempio ai grandissimi
benefici che intelligenza artificiale
machine learning tecnologie intelligenti
hanno portato all'interno dei della
sanità oggi i medici riescono a
raccogliere condividere analizzare in
maniera molto più veloce ed efficiente
i dati dei propri pazienti riescono ad
analizzare i dati dei propri pazienti in
modo da indirizzare in maniera più
tempestiva e veloce le terapie da
adottare
attraverso l'analisi dei dati si riesce
individuare in maniera precoce delle
malattie ad esempio generati
ereditarie o delle malattie rare e poi
applicato ovviamente alla ricerca
oncologica sono stati fatti giganteschi
passi avanti altri casi ma se ne
potrebbero si potrebbe stare qua tutto
il giorno a dirle a raccontarli 1 in cui
siamo sono stata coinvolta personalmente
una ricerca fatta con l'università di
genova all'ospedale di genova in cui
sono stati prototipati dei pantaloni
intelligenti per i pazienti colpiti da
ictus per la riabilitazione re pazienti
colpiti da ictus
anziché dover tornare per la
riabilitazione ogni volta in ospedale
attraverso l'utilizzo di questi
pantaloni
il medico può da remoto analizzare i
vari movimenti che il presidente compie
modo da capire se stabia ambulanza nella
maniera corretta
si sta facendo tutte le tappe della
riabilitazione maniera corretta e col
mio lavoro io spesso tutti i giorni mi
trovo a dialogare con gli imprenditori è
in dubbio lo sentiamo tutti i giorni in
televisione che l'italia leggermente
indietro nell'adozione delle tecnologie
all'interno delle organizzazioni ma ci
sono vi garantisco delle bellissime
aspettative per il futuro
e tutti gli imprenditori tra l'altro cui
ho domandato che come la vedono no
l'ingresso delle tecnologie perché poi
si sente luoghi comuni robot le
tecnologie andranno a rubare il lavoro
dell'uomo
le due termini che più spesso emergono
durante le conversazioni con gli
imprenditori di qualsiasi segmento
facciano e si parte fashion automotive
agrifood qualsiasi tipo rete il
qualsiasi tipo di segmento emergono
creatività e dignità umana le tecnologie
oggi possono alleggerire l'uomo da tutti
quei lavori di bassissimo valore
ripetitivi e noiosi e noi possiamo
guardare in noi stessi per creare valore
e per andare a portare quel grandissimo
valore e creatività che è sempre stato
il bello dell'eccellenza italiana del
nostro made in italy siamo riconosciuti
a livello mondiale per la bellezza dei
nostri prodotti
torniamo a
tre creativi e a crederci e poi i robot
come diceva isaac asimov all'inizio del
novecento è stato uno dei precursori
della robotica il modellamento delle
intelligenze artificiali è per il
momento nelle nostre mani e io credo che
ci rimarrà a cui solo aggiungo io sta a
noi programmarle in modo che non siano
in futuro un'amica da temere ma che
siano esattamente ciò per cui sono state
create uno strumento che ci aiuti a
comprendere il mondo e viverlo nei
migliori dei modi
quindi i robot difficilmente ruberà il
lavoro degli umani
anche perché nessuna macchina potrà mai
mai sostituire l'empatia le emozioni le
relazioni umane e le ispirazioni che
sono proprio dell'uomo
per me è stato un grandissimo piacere
passare su questo palco vi ringrazio per
l'attenzione con proseguimento di serata
[Applauso]